. Scheint, man erstrahlt das Wunder der Freundschaft und leuchtet uns den Weg durch finstere Nacht. Und richtig schöne Männer sind das, sie haben mir nichts als Glück gebracht. Also in die Pizza einfach nur goili-goi. Jetzt gibt es wieder Podcast-Tricks, was kostet das? Sie lasst sich der fliegenden Untertassen, wunderbar, es war das ganze Superklasse klasse, super klasse. Hey, hallo und herzlich willkommen zu dieser neuen Ausgabe. Wow! D, P, U, das Podcast UFO mit Stefan Dietz und Florentin Will. Schön, dass ihr mit dabei seid. Heute werden wir eingeleitet von Jorkel und Farmer. Jorkel und Farmer? Richtig, es waren zwei, ich kann dir leider leider nicht sagen, wer wer, ich hätte gerne immer das Libretto auch mitgeschickt beim Intro, damit ich das nochmal, klar, musikanalytische Betrachtung ist immer gesehen, gut gesehen, aber natürlich auch gerne würde ich das unterhalten können, wie viele Posaunen waren das jetzt, wie viele Fasanen waren das jetzt, wie viele Männer waren im Raume. Aber gut, das ist optional, wie gesagt, Intro first, ist immer schon unsere Püte gewesen, Libretto second. Vielen Dank auch von mir, ich fand das ganz fantastisch, das war irgendwie so ein Oldschool-Intro. Man merkt, man löst sich vom Florentin-Regime, die strenge 10 bis maximal 12 Sekunden-Regel wird hier und da ein bisschen freier ausgenutzt. Ich sehe das nicht gerne, muss ich sagen. Also ich möchte da gerne wieder den Korken rein, wenn es trägt. Aber der Korken liegt bereit. Wenn es sein muss, stecke ich den wieder rein in die Pipeline und dann ist erst mal Schluss. Du kannst auch mal hart abschneiden, mal gucken, wie die Leute das da draußen finden. Ich glaube, die finden das gar nicht gut. Da gab es schon einige kleinere Shit-Dürmchen, Shit-Winchen, die da hier und da durch das Reddit gezogen sind, aufgrund meiner Schnittkünste.
Ich fand das toll, ganz tolles Intro, vielen Dank. Ich bin drin, ich bin drin, also ich muss sagen, ich bin direkt drin. Jetzt allerdings müssen wir ganz viel sagen, wenn ihr im Intro Dinge versprecht oder sowas wie, wir würden hier Podcast-Tricks. Das wäre sehr lustig. So, das ist natürlich für uns schwierig, weil es ist eine missliche Situation, weil jetzt wurden euch ja offiziell Podcast-Tricks versprochen, ohne genau jetzt zu erklären, was, also so eine Art Zaubertrick oder so eine Art wie man Fingerbord oder so Karten zählen oder so, da bin ich jetzt ein bisschen in der Luft, um ganz ehrlich zu sein, da schwimme ich gerade ein bisschen. Ich verspüre so einen unangenehmen Druck, weil man jetzt natürlich irgendwie so eine Erwartungshaltung aufgebaut hat im Intro, die wir nicht zwangsläufig aufrechterhalten können. Du gehst ja legendär schlecht mit Druck um. Also das ist ja wirklich weit bekannt. Das ist ja so das Erste, was man hört bei Stefan Tietze, Wunderkind und dann aber geht legendär schlecht mit Druck um. Also knickt sofort ein wie so ein Kartenhaus. Wie ein Kartenhaus falle ich dann und liege so zerflossen am Boden und sag ...
Und will man es dann noch mal aufbauen? Das ist dann immer die Frage. Wenn du es einmal aufgebaut hast, dein Kartenhaus, dann kommt jemand als Prank und macht es kaputt. Und dann baut man es noch mal auf? Ich weiß es nicht. Und dann pustet jemand um, nimmt eine Karte hoch und sagt, und, war deine Karte die Peak acht? Und du sagst, ja, hä? Aber würdest du dich dann freuen, also wenn jemand dein Kartenhaus kaputt macht, aber mit der Karte, die du im Sinn hast, und dann liegt einerseits dein Kartenhaus in Trümmern, wie der Turm von Babylon, von Babbel, von Babbel, und andererseits sagst du aber, ich habe tatsächlich an die Herzzehn gedacht. Ja, das ist ein bisschen wie, deine Frau wird auf der Bühne zersägt in so einem Sägekasten und danach sagt er dir, wie sie heisst, was er irgendwie herausgefunden hat oder sowas. Da ist dann die Frage, okay, coole Auflösung des Tricks, mein Kartenhaus, figurativ gesprochen, ist halt auf dem Weg kaputt gegangen.
Richtig. Ähm, nee, ich glaub, so funktionieren Taubertricks nicht, die müssen immer nur geil sein, ob, ja, also das Ding ist, bei mir werden gerade im Internet, in den Feeds dieser Welt immer die Auflösungen nur noch gezeigt. Ach so, das ist interessant, weil ich habe nur das Setup. Also gar keine Tricks mehr. Ich habe immer nur das Setup. Das heißt, ich glaube, unser Algorithmus hat sich genau geteilt zwischen uns. Nee, ich meine sogar, es werden die Hände, was hinter den Händen passiert. Ach so. Also ich habe so eine Magier-POV sozusagen bekommen, wo die Tricks erklärt werden, so Magier mit der Maske Style. Ich glaube, es gibt zwar unterschiedliche Algorithmen. Es gibt den Setup-Algorithmus und den Pay-off-Algorithmus. Ich habe zum Beispiel in so einem Video gesehen von jemandem, der hat so Federschuhe, der hat sich Schuhe gekauft und hat dann so Metallfedern da drunter geklebt. Wie Samuel Koch. So mit ... Wo wir alle wissen, dass da nichts schiefgehen kann. Genau, und der hat sozusagen eine zweite Sohle in 20 cm Abstand noch mal unter die eigene Sohle gemacht und dann aber Federn dazu. Und dann hat er es gemacht und reingegossen mit Plastik und so. Und dann hat er gesagt, so, und jetzt probiere ich es mal aus. Cut. Ja, gut, so nehme ich TikTok auch wahr. Und ich dachte mir, okay, scroll weiter. Aber so, ich bin zufrieden, ich bin aufgeladen wie die Feder quasi, ich bin reingedrückt, aber ich kann auch weitergehen. Und du hast vielleicht genau das Gegenstück. Nee, bei mir steht da unten immer, das habe ich auch wohl manchmal, und da steht unten diese Suche, das ist ganz merkwürdig, steht dann drunter Sprungfeder-Typ Teil zwei zum Beispiel. Ja. Also das wird aber in dem Video nie erwähnt. Nee. Das basiert nur, was dann viele Leute gesucht haben, nachdem sie das Video gesehen haben. Das ist so eine Lupe und ein Springfeder-Typ Teil zwei. Und dann kann man das suchen. Glück findet man das dann. Um es euch zu ersparen, er ist leider gestürzt und ist jetzt leider ... Ja, also mein Trick, also wäre vielleicht unter diese Samuel-Koch-Schuhe da noch Sprungfedern dran zu machen. Ja, okay, aber welche oben, welche unten? Also die sieben Meilen unten und dann die Stahlfedern drunter? Jetzt komme ich mit den sieben Meilenstiefeln. Ja, ich meine, sorry, wir hatten ja alle schon mal die Idee, eine Matratze ist gemütlich, zwei Matratzen, noch gemütlicher Fragezeichen, lege ich einfach auf die Matratze noch eine Matratze. Topper, ein Topper. Ja, oder weil ich hatte zum Beispiel lange Zeit kein Bett, ich hatte statt einem Bett eine Matratze. Genau. Also ich hatte zwei Matratzen aufeinander, Big Mac, und das war eine herrliche Zeit. Eine Matratze, sag mal, bist du bescheuert, du hast dein Leben nicht im Griff, zwei Matratzen, oh, japanisches Futon. Du hast wirklich, oh, der Mann hat es geschafft. Bist du reich? Wow, richtig schön. Aber da fragt man sich auch, also geht das, weil ich meine, manche Dinge kann man addieren, andere nicht. Ja, love it. Das ist schon so. Und bei Matratzen bin ich mir nicht sicher, ob man das einfach direkt ... Nee, ja, wie gesagt, es gibt Topper. Topper sind im Prinzip kleine Matratzen, die du auf deiner Matratze packst. Also stell dir vor, du hast im Winter ... im Sommer ist es heiß. Oh Gott, ich wollte ihn sprechen. Im Sommer ist es heiß und du hast einen Ventilator. Zum Beispiel. Und du lässt dich von dem anblasen und denkst dir, das gibt mir nicht das, was ich brauche. Und denkst dir, ich stelle hinter den Ventilator noch einen Ventilator. So, aber ich glaube, auch das kann man nicht addieren. Manche Dinge kann man nicht addieren, dass der dann doppelt so schnellen Wind erzeugt. Oder vielleicht doch, ich weiß nicht, er darf nur nicht in die falsche Richtung. Also er betreibt den anderen. Du meinst, er erzeugt die Energie, die dann der Erste braucht. Das wäre ja meine Idee. Er stellt ein Windrad auf und dann stellt davor ein anderes Windrad.
Und das erste ist aber nicht mit Wind betrieben, sondern elektrisch. Und ihr treibt mit diesem Windrad die anderen Windräder in Reihe geschaltet, die anderen Windräder an. Dann hast du diese ganzen Nachbarn in Brandenburg, die sagen, ihr baut mir hier nicht noch Windräder vor die Tür, sondern vor allem, wer will kein Windrad vor der Tür? Ich bin neulich auf der Autobahn lang gebrettert. Und rechts sieht man dann manchmal so LKWs, die mit so Blinklichtern gekennzeichnet, Schwertransporter, die diese Flügel transportieren. Die sind so riesig. Und ich denke, ich habe das beim ersten Mal gedacht, das kann ja wirklich sein. Und dann beim zweiten Mal dachte ich, die sind ja unglaublich riesig. Und immer noch bin ich genauso amazed. Ich sehe jetzt, weiß ich nicht, seit 15 Jahren regelmäßig die auf der Autobahn und meine Reaktion hat sich nicht verändert. Es ist immer noch geil. Ich bin immer noch, what, what, guck mal wie groß das ist. Es ist so gut, ich habe einmal so ein Video gesehen, wo jemand einen Basketball so in die Luft wirft und der dann so von dem Flügel weggedotzt wird.
Ja.
Und ich mir so, unfassbar.
Okay, ja. Guck mal, wie groß das ist! Es ist so gut, ich hab einmal so ein Video gesehen, wo jemand Basketball so in die Luft wirft und der dann so von dem Flügel weggedotzt wird. Ja. Unfassbar. Tatsächlich ist es ja so, ich hab als Kind früher gerne Sim City gespielt und hab dort nur Windräder gebaut, bis zu dem Punkt, dass meine Brüder angefangen haben, Windräder Teenie-Dreher zu nennen. Also immer wenn die dann Sim City gespielt haben und die gebaut haben, haben wir gesagt, ich baue noch ein paar Teenie-Dreher, weil ich die so gern mochte. Nur das ist wirklich der Laughingstock deiner Familie. Rückblickend ist es Mobbing. Also rückblickend ist es wirklich gehässigstes Mobbing. Komm, mach mal ein paar Teenie-Dreher da rein. Aber war das eine gute Taktik? Also war das eigentlich, haben die das nachgebaut, weil es eine gute Taktik war? Das weiß ich nicht. Also ich musste halt schon immer so gut die Hälfte der Map mit Teenie-Drehen zu pflastern, aber es hat mir immer gut gefallen. Ich fand das immer eine feine Sache. Aber ich habe die auch immer in unterschiedliche Richtungen gebaut, weil ich dachte, na gut, was ist, wenn der Wind von der anderen Seite kommt? Aber was ist, wenn das Windrad falsch rumdreht? Kann das sich falsch rumdrehen? Also wenn jetzt plötzlich der Wind von der anderen Seite käme, in einem grausamen Streich Gottes, der sagt,
lasst mal euren Klimascheiss da,
lasst mal eure Klimahysterie,
euer Klimagagat, Bullshit da so.
Mach mal Osten.
Wie heißt er?
Gabriel?
Gabriel, mach, dreh mal
den Wind um.
Hallo? Gabriel,
dreh mal den Wind um. Einfach ausscheissen. Wie Wind umdrehen. Einfach mal ausscheiss, gerade umdrehen. Einfach mal von der anderen Seite. Horizontal drehen oder vertikal drehen? Nee, du meinst von unten nach oben, oder was? Das ist auch geil. Ja, das ist auch geil. Mach mal Wind von unten nach oben. Geil, mach mal. Okay. Mach mal. Mach mal. Wie jetzt? Jetzt oder was? Und ich mach wieder den Busch. Ich mach wieder den brennenden Busch, oder? Oh, nicht der brennende Busch. Geil, mach mal. Was ist die Lehre von dem brennenden Busch, Sir? Was heißt hier Lehre, Mann? Das war eine saudumme Aktion. Die war besoffen wie blöd. Glaubst du, diese Ambrosia lässt dich komplett kalt, oder was? Komm, willst du auch mal naschen? Kriegen Sie ihn hier alleine im Büro? Ist das dann eine Bierflasche in der Ecke, oder was? Hä, weißt Quatsch, das ist von gestern Abend. Hä, wie wie sind das Bierflaschen in der Ecke? Hä, das ist ja alles von gestern Abend. Das hat ja nichts mit dem heutigen Tag zu tun. Sollen Sie da ein Fachmann stehen? Ne, was? Quatsch? Hä, nein! Sie waren auch sehr lange nicht mehr zu Hause, ist alles wirklich gut bei Ihnen? Das ist alles, ja gut, klar, ich meine... Decke auf dem Sofa, die schlafen doch hier. Quatsch, ihr habt mich kurz ausgeruhigt, ihr habt mich kurz hingelegt, mit den Augen ausgeruht.
Aphrodite ist gerade so ein bisschen
hier mit den Schlangenhaaren und so
und der Friseur hat wieder alles.
Das ist, ich sag dir,
egal, was ich jetzt brauche,
was ich jetzt brauche, ist,
ich kenne mich gut genug,
dass ich weiss.
Herr Präsident,
ich muss Ihnen sagen, wir sind alle recht besorgt, Sie haben krasse Augenringe und Sie erschaffen halt die Leute nach Ihrem Aussehen. Deswegen wäre uns wichtig, dass Sie besser, also wir helfen, weil Sie alles nach Ihrem Antlitz entstehen lassen, wäre es schön, wenn Sie sich besser sorgen würden um sich. Ich habe mir letztes Jahr Fett absaugen lassen wegen eurem scheiß Brandbrief da. Was haben Sie? Wegen eurem scheiß Brandbrief. Da kam in den stillen Briefkasten, kam lauter Nachrichten, ich sei zu Fett, habe ich mir extra Fett absaugen lassen. In Ungarn, bin ich extra nach Ungarn gefahren. Hast du eine Ahnung, wie es als brennender Busch im fucking Zug nach Ungarn ist? Wie der brennende Busch, das müssen Sie ja nicht ... Mir würde es so freuen, wenn Sie mal den Betriebsbüchologen aufsuchen könnten, weil irgendwie, sie schlafen hier im Büro, offensichtlich hier riecht's. Nee. Wie so ein Nerd, der ist cool, wir mögen den alle, der wurde wieder einstimmig gewählt zu einer neuen Amtszeit. Ach, vielleicht, ja. Ich meine, was soll mir der diagnostizieren? Also sehr wann schlafen Sie im Büro? Also jetzt seit dem zweiten Tag. Also am ersten Tag habe ich Licht und Schatten geschaffen und am zweiten Tag ging es schon abwärts. Aber haben Sie eine Deadline für Ihr Projekt Erde? Also haben Sie sieben Tage? Ich dachte, fünf Tage mache ich. Also beim fünften will ich fertig sein. Okay, das wird knapp. Ja, gut, das hilft mir nicht, dass Sie mir das sagen, wenn ich hier sitze. Ich meine, ich habe da noch die ganzen Pflanzen rumstehen und Flüsse und alles. Ja, ich bin saugestresst von der Scheiße. Scheiße. Ja. Was war Ihre Idee, Projekt Erde und Menschheit und Licht und Wasser? Naja, ich wollte halt so zwei Nackte, die da halt so ... Okay, was wollen diese beiden Nackten? Naja, was wollen die schon? Kultus, sie wollen miteinander schlafen. Die wollen zwei Menschen dabei zugucken, wie sie miteinander schlafen. Die sie nach ihrem Antlitz erschaffen haben, das heißt, sie wollen sich selber beim Kultus sehen, ist das richtig? Ja, na ja, also was sollen die sonst machen? Also der ist ja sonst nix. Essen, Gedichte schreiben, Musik machen. Ja, klar, aber irgendwann, mal so abends. Also sie wollen eine Frau und einen Mann, haben sie auch keine Klamotten gegeben, warum? Nee, warum auch nicht? Brauchen die doch nicht. Na ja, wenn sie den Apfel essen würden, dann würden sie sowas wie Scham. Den Apfel lassen wir gerade mal raus, ja? Okay, wir können den Apfel aus der Gleichung lassen. Okay, ich würde den Apfel für heute gerne einfach mal komplett rauslassen. Würden Sie sich selber gerne beim Sex zugucken? Naja. Schon? Okay, dann haben Sie... Das wirkt wie ein Durchbruch, das wirkt wie ein Durchbruch, den wir in dieser Hitzung haben, im Narzissmus. Ah, aha. Ich drücke Ihnen da kurz ein Rezept aus. Was kann man da machen? Ja, was ist das? Da müsste man jetzt ganz lange daran forschen, tausende Jahre, da müsste so ein reicher, krasser, cleverer Österreicher um die Ecke kommen, der kommt da bestimmt auf tolle Ergebnisse, dann so ein Franzose vielleicht, noch ein paar, ein Schweizer und dann Forschung, Forschung, Forschung und irgendwann kriegt man das vielleicht therapeutisch in den Griff. Ich bin da noch an den Anfängen. Dann warte ich, ne? Dann warte ich, warten wir noch ein paar. 1900 Jahre, 2000 Jahre dauert das. Ja, ja, ja, na gut. Das wird schon nicht, das wird schon meine Schöpfung nicht beeinflussen, glaube ich. Da kann ich mir nicht vorstellen. Aber es beeinflusste die Schöpfung. Ende. Gut. Ja, Turm zu Babel, ne? Haben die gebaut und dann komplett in Sand gesetzt. Turmbau zu Babel. Gibt es denn also so Fundamentalisten, Christen, Flat-Earther, Extremisten, Christen, Leute, die dann den suchen, den Turm? Extra Christen, wäre mein Vorschlag.
Für eine Lokalistengruppe oder so? Ja. Wo man sich lustig macht übers Christentum? Eine Mitschülerin war mal damals, das war ja diese beliebte Zeit, wo alle Auslandssemester, Schuljahr machen wollten. Ich glaube, damals war es ein halbes Jahr oder wie lange man in den Schuljahren weg war. Das weiß ich gar nicht mehr. Und sie war weg und kam wieder. Und die war halt, alle wollen ja nach Kalifornien, träumen sich ja so ein geiles Schuljahr in New York oder so. Sie war mitten im Bible Belt und kam wieder als fundamentale Christin. Also so richtig extreme Christin. Ein halbes Jahr hat gereicht. Ja, das wäre jetzt die Frage. Ich meine, ja, ein halbes Jahr. Das ist beeindruckend. Zack. Nicht schlecht. Eine fundamentale Christin. Ja. Ja, das wäre jetzt die Frage. Ich meine, ja, halbes Jahr. Das ist beeindruckend. Zack.
Nicht schlecht. Fundamentale Christin. Ja. Wo man denkt, das ist schon sehr intensiv. Das war so ein bisschen New Turn. Ja, aber laden die die extra dafür ein? Du meinst, hier ist ein Bible Belt? Also es ist eine geheime Idee, dass sie sagen, wir machen Austausch und so, und dann wollen die die alle einfach nur indoktrinieren oder so? Ja, vielleicht. Ja, vielleicht, kann gut sein. Früher sind die Missionare halt dann irgendwie nach Japan gefahren oder nach Sri Lanka und dann sind die da halt umgebracht worden. Und jetzt denkt man sich, nee, nee, nee, nee, wir holen die her, wir holen die hierher, dann kann da mal einer aus Burkina-Faso kommt, her Austauschen, dann missionieren wir den hier, schicken wir den wieder zurück, ist doch viel schlauer, viel schlauer. Das ist super smart. Richtig, richtig schlauer. Ja, und es hat mega bei der geklappt. Und dann war die so richtig am Start. So richtig Arche und alles. Die hat angefangen, im Einflügel der Schule eine Arche zu bauen. Und dann hat sie die ganze Zeit gesagt, Sünder, ihr werdet alle sterben. Und wen hätte sie mitgenommen?
Ungläubige, ihr werdet alle sterben.
Ja, ja, ja.
Dann gab es so einen Elternabend und dann haben wir sie nicht mehr gesehen.
Also es war ein bisschen tragisch tatsächlich.
Ist ja die Frage, wenn du eine Arche baust, wen nimmst du mit?
Zwei von jeder Sorte.
Genau, aber auch zwei Menschen ja auch.
Nee, aber in der Schule nimmst du zwei von jeder Sorte, du nimmst zwei Fussballer. Ach so, zwei Nerds. Also du nimmst einen Fussballer, eine Fussballerin. Du nimmst einen Nerd und eine Nerdin. Du nimmst einen Theater-Guy-Kit, leider Schwul, und einen Theater-Girl mit. Also du nimmst von jedem, genau, einen Versager, eine Versagerin. Und so läuft das. Also einfach mal eine komplette Mischung. Ein Lehrer, eine Lehrerin. Ein Sportlehrer, eine Sportlehrerin. Ein Sekretär, eine Sekretärin. Die Frage ist, wer kommt da nicht mit? Weil hat nicht jeder so eine Rolle zu spielen in der Schule. Also ist nicht jeder irgendwie so ein Archetyp letzten Endes auf der Archite. Jeder ist ja auf so einen Breakfast-Club-mässige Rolle einzutieren. Ja, Celebrations, du hast die Twix-Typen, du hast die Dove-Typen, die Bounty-Typen, so wir alle wissen, wen wir mögen und wer eigentlich lieber nicht mitfahren soll. Weil ich stell mir halt vor, dass am Ende die Schuleiche losfällt und es bleibt halt nur so eine Person zurück. Und dann sagt er sich, okay, wolltet ihr euch von einer grossen Sinnflut retten oder wolltet ihr einfach nur mich? Das ist wie wenn du eine neue WhatsApp-Gruppe machst, wo du alle mit reinnimmst, ausser eine Person. Du denkst dir so, das ist euch jetzt lieber, als einfach mich rauszuschmeissen. So am Arche-Projekt, weil da bin ich jetzt nicht eingeladen worden. Ja, das ist leider, wie gesagt, zwei von jeder Sorte und du bist leider der dritte Naht und deswegen haben wir uns da für Justus und Judith entschieden. Also explizit gegen mich, da kann ich einfach auch mitnehmen. Aber zwei von, nee, zwei von jedem, das war die Idee und das wollen wir jetzt am Ende nicht kaputt machen. Vielleicht ist es lustig, wenn am Ende die Nachkommen alle aussehen wie der Horte Sportler. Ja, das war genau, die Zimmer waren recht nah beieinander auf der Arche. Ja, so war das, ich hoffe, der geht's gut. Ich weiß gar nicht, was die jetzt macht. Ja, meld dich mal, also wie läuft das? Das ist vielleicht ja gar nicht schlecht. Also vielleicht ist die auf der Suche nach dem Turm zu Babel, dass man da sagt, weil die haben ja, wollten ja einen riesigen Turm bauen. Wollt deine Mutter nicht auch mal den Turm zu bauen?
Nee, das Bernsteinzimmer. Das Bernsteinzimmer suchen. Und ist sie da weitergekommen? Da kam aktuell, es gab eine Neuigkeit irgendwo, sind irgendwelche Kisten aufgetaucht oder sowas in der Richtung. Ich habe es in unserem Reddit gesehen, vielen Dank da nochmal. Aber irgendwas kam da aktuell und ich weiß immer nicht, ob ich sowas an meine Mutter weiterleiten soll oder nicht. Also aktuelle News. Aber auch nicht, also wovor hast du Angst? Naja, weil jetzt, wenn es jetzt heißt, okay,
da wurden jetzt Kisten am Bahnhof in Brüssel
gefunden, will ich nicht, dass meine
Mutter entweder aufgibt oder sich sofort
ihren Mantel anzieht und nach Brüssel wetzt?
Ich weiß nicht, wie sehr ich da...
Warum willst du nicht, dass deine Mutter nach Brüssel geht?
Das kann ihr ja eigentlich egal sein.
Eigentlich könnte es sich freuen, wenn deine Mutter für einen Trip nach Brüssel.
Ja, eigentlich schon, aber ich weiß, ich will ja nicht, dass sie sich überlastet. Also, dass sie dir jetzt schnell irgendwie alle stehen und liegen. Für die sich belastend einen Trip nach Brüssel in eine schöne Stadt. Ja, aber dass sie da irgendwie am Bahnhof irgendwelche Kisten aufmacht und da rumwühlt. Ich weiß ja nicht genau, was ihre Vorstellung ist, wie sie sich das vorstellt. Weil wenn du sagst, ich will das Bernsteinzimmer finden, dann stelle ich mir nicht vor, ah, ich lese eine Schlagzeile in der Zeitung, fahr da hin und mach die Kiste auf. Weil wirklich gefunden hat man es dann ja nicht. Aber übertreibst du nicht vielleicht ein bisschen zu viel, wollen wir nicht, also, wie hat es sich denn formuliert, weil wir wollen ja alle das Bernsteinzimmer finden. Also es ist ja nicht, trotzdem ist unsere Suche unbeeindruckt davon. Also ich suche jetzt nicht aktiv, ich würde es gerne finden, aber du hast ja keine Sorgen machen, dass ich nach Brüssel vor den Kisten öffne, ungefragt, weil ich jetzt nicht aktiv danach suche. Ja, genau, also sie hat gesagt, sie würde gerne das Bernsteinzimmer finden. Sie hat jetzt nicht gesagt, dass sie aktiv auf der Suche ist notwendigerweise. Es ist wahrscheinlich eine ähnliche Situation wie bei dir, wo wenn es vor die Füsse fällt. Dann sagt sie nicht nein. Dann sagt sie nicht, aber das wollte ich nicht finden. Genau, nee, nee. Sie würde sich da nicht umdrehen und sagen, wie überhaupt, da will ich gar nichts zu tun haben. Da gibt es ja auch solche Leute, gibt ja Leute, die sich dann gar nicht wollen. Weiß ich nicht, Florin hies. Aber naja, ich sag mal, es gibt ja Leute, die genießen die Suche. Die wollen das ja, wenn sie es gefunden haben, was dann? So, die wollen es ja immer suchen. Deswegen, glaube ich, ist das Bernsteinzimmer ja ein gutes Ziel, weil du wirst es ja wahrscheinlich, also gar nicht negativ gemeint, aber es wird ja nicht passieren, also du wirst es ja nicht schaffen. Es wird ja nicht funktionieren, du wirst es ja nicht schaffen. Du glaubst halt gar nicht an seine Mutter.
Also ich sag mal so, wenn sie sich mehr Mühe geben würde, wenn sie da jetzt mehr ... Sie hat drei Jungs rumgroßgezogen. Ja. Warum nicht Bernsteinzimmer finden? Ja, ich weiß auch nicht, inwiefern sie sich vielleicht erwartet hat, dass ich das übernehme. Also dass sie das so sagt, das wäre schon noch mein Wunsch, einmal das Bernsteinzimmer zu finden. Zwinker, zwinker, im Sinne von, du als mein Spross, den ich in die Welt gesetzt habe, sollst das jetzt machen. Vielleicht liegt die Verantwortung … Oh, hau dir die Geschenke dieses Jahr. Ah, und für Florentin einen dieser Spaten und für deinen Bruder Worentin dieser Kompass und für den anderen Bruder Worentin kriegt hier mal diese Peitsche. Oh wow, danke, wow, super. Wir haben dir jetzt hier den neuen, den neuen Thriller von Isabel Flink. Nee, nee, brauche ich nicht. Gar nicht? Da geht's um Görings Kunstschatz. Ah, das finde ich ja auch nicht so schlimm, den zu finden. Ach so. Ah, okay. Aber also, Bernsteinzimmer schon auf eins oder was ist noch was ganz anderes auf eins? Ach, wenn mir das jemand abnehmen könnte, diese Suche, diese stürige Suche. Haben wir noch Dominosteine? Nee. Ach, vielleicht da hinten in der Schatztruhe. Ah, dann hol ich welche. Will noch jemand Vanillekipferl? Nee. Ich will nur das Bernsteinzimmer. Ja, ach, wir gucken ja jetzt nach einer neuen Wohnung. Wo guckt ihr da? Na? Wo, wie genau guckt ihr da? Weihnachten jedes Jahr bei Wills. Aha, mhm. Wo sucht ihr da? Bernstein brennt ja auch, ne, und ist ja auch magnetisch zu einem Teil. Was, Bernstein ist magnetisch? Wusstest ihr, dass Bernstein schwimmt? Mama, wir haben doch gerade was ganz anderes gesprochen. Ja, ja, ja, nee, weil ich meinte nur, weil du gerade meintest, du willst noch eine Cola. Nee, ich meinte nicht, weil ich meinen Doktor gemacht habe. Ja, super. In Archäologie oder? Was? Nein, Psychologie. Ach so. Wie, ach so. Ja. Hä? Also Bernstein schwimmt ja, also man könnte ja auch vielleicht, also wenn es jetzt ins Meer gefallen wäre. Das Zimmer? Das Zimmer, das komplette Zimmer. Kann ja sein, dass es weggeschwommen ist, also entweder ein Fluss entlang, Flussläufe entlang oder an einem Ufer. Ich finde das so lustig, wenn sie das wirklich findet. Das wäre wirklich geil. Es wäre wirklich richtig. Es wäre wirklich gut. Es würde den Podcast auch guttun. Es würde uns wirklich gut tun.
Es wäre eine gewisse Publicity, obwohl müsste man halt gucken.
Ich weiß nicht, würde ich da meiner Mutter sagen, kannst du bitte, wenn jetzt Focus Online hier vor der Tür steht und dich interviewt zum Thema Bernsteinzimmer,
könntest du erwähnen, dass du die Mutter bist von dem Podcast-Host, Florentin Will von das Podcast-UFO. Ginge das?
Weißt du, was ich geil fände gerade? Wenn wir eine Spezialfolge machen, wo wir mit deiner Mutter aktiv anfangen, das Bernsteinzimmer zu suchen. Also wirklich mal so Rucksack packen. Wir nehmen die Mikros mit, Karte. Vielleicht eine Kamera und machen so eine Spezialfolge, das Podcast UFO unterwegs auf grosser Schatzsuche.
Ja.
Und wir suchen mit deiner Mutter das Bernsteinzimmer, aber eigentlich geht es darum, zu dir und deiner Mutter zu finden, also zu gucken, wo kommst du her, wer bist du eigentlich, also aber, und es ist sozusagen der Weg das Ziel, das finde ich schön. Ich weiß nicht, ob das meiner Mutter gefällt, Weg ist das Ziel. Ich glaube, meine Mutter hat ganz konkrete Zielvorstellungen. Was ist der Weg zum Ziel? Genau, ja, genau. Der Weg ist der Weg zum Ziel. Also ich kenne mich jetzt Schmach auf meinem Haupt nicht so gut mit dem Bernsteinzimmer aus, aber ich glaube, das ist so Ecke Russland, oder? Also das ist jetzt kein Wochenendaufflug oder so. Meine Mutter fährt dieses Jahr noch nach Zypern auf eine Studienreise und ich fände es lustig, wenn sie das da findet. Weil sie sucht danach nicht. Explizit nicht. Und es fällt dir so vor die Füsse, dass du am Strand so Aua! Was ist denn das da? Lassen die Leute den ganzen Müll rum rumliegen hier rum? Was ist denn überhaupt? Das ist ein Zimmer. Ein Bernstein-Zimmer. Es ist ein Bernstein-Zimmer. Als wäre das so ein geflügelter Begriff. Das ist so geil. Wir lassen hier sein ganzes Bernstein-Zimmer am Strand rumliegen. Ja, und dann taucht es irgendwann auf. Also, es ist natürlich auch, wäre es für eine Kurzgeschichte oder einen Kurzfilm oder ein TikTok oder sowas, dass jemand wirklich das, dass jemand das Bernsteinzimmer findet, was macht man dann? So, ne, also, dann würde man, okay, dann gehst du zu einem Kunstherr, der sagt, ich kaufe Ihnen das ab, für 5000 Euro. Das Bernsteinzimmer für 5000 Euro? Das war 10.000 Euro. Okay. Was ist ein, also, was ist ein realistischer Preis? Weil das ist nämlich das, was ich mir immer denke. Angenommen, du findest das Bernsteinzimmer und du verkaufst es jetzt für 10 Millionen Euro. Und dann kommt raus, das wurde weiterverkauft für 500 Millionen Euro. Also du wurdest komplett über den Tisch gezogen. Ja. Wie sehr könntest du die 10 Millionen Euro geniessen? Es ist immer noch wahnsinnig viel Geld, viel mehr, als du jemals brauchst.
Aber du denkst dir, ich hätte 50 Mal so viel haben können. Ist es dann, also ich könnte mir einen Roman oder eine Limerick oder was auch immer, Haiku vorstellen, von jemandem, der dann sehr unglücklich wird, sogar vielleicht noch unglücklicher, als er davor war, als er ein bescheidenes Einkommen hatte, weil er sich mit jedem Euro, den er ausgibt, denkt, ah fuck, ich hätte mir 50 Mal so viel leisten.
Ja, finde ich super.
Und dann denke ich mir so, will ich überhaupt das Bernsteinzimmer finden? Also will ich überhaupt irgendwas finden, was ein abstraktes...
Und da bist du, wenn deine Mutter wirklich ganz anders, was spannend ist, weil sie dich ja jetzt so gewissermaßen geprägt hat auch, aber während du es nicht finden willst, weil du denkst, ah, ich verkaufe das billig weiter,
würde deine Mutter sagen, nee, ich will, der Weg ist der Weg zum Ziel. Richtig. Interessant, dass sie es Bernstein mal finden will und ich gerade nicht. Was mich so abschreckt. Pest und Cholera komplett gegensetzen. Was mich komplett abschreckt an diesem Schatz, das ist der Begriff Zimmer. Weil Zimmer sagt für mich Teil eines Raums oder ein Raum in einem Haus, in einer vorgebenden Struktur, in einem Schloss.
Ja, das ist schön definiert, ja, Zimmer.
So, und das ist ja gemeinhin erschlossen.
Weißt du, also jetzt der Schatz von Hernan Cortes, irgendwo in Mariannen-Graben, sehr unrealistisch den zu finden, so eine Kiste ist sehr kleiner als ein Zimmer, ergo unrealistischer zu finden auf unserem blauen Planetchen. Richtig. Trotzdem finde ich es irgendwie attraktiver, weil ich denke, ja, wahrscheinlich ist der zu finden. Das Zimmer ist vermutlich rausgeraubt worden, leergeräumt worden, verteilt worden auf der Welt, also ein Zimmer ist so unattraktiv zu finden. Ja, es eine Frage, es ist ein komplett intaktes Zimmer, ne, also dass du irgendwann so bei Burger King, du willst mal aufs Klo. Aber wenn ein Zimmer nicht intakt ist, kein Zimmer mehr, weißt du, was ich meine? Ich verstehe schon, aber du würdest es ja nicht teilen, also würdest du sagen, ich hab hier das Bernsteinzimmer. Ich nehm so zwei, drei Stücke, also, ne, also ich nehm so 200 Gramm davon, so, du würdest es ja nicht machen, das ist ja Quatsch, du musst ja sagen, das ist komplett Bernsteinzimmer, also da würde ich auch sagen, du nimmst jetzt nicht von der Mona Lisa da so das oberes Stück, so, ich nehme so das obere Drittel, so gewisse Kunstwerke müssen schon erhalten bleiben, so, das kannst du ja nicht machen, das ist dann immer so dieser Move der Pen and Paper Runde, die sagt, ich trinke den halben Heiltrank oder so. Nee, ganz oder gar nicht. Und da würde ich ähnliche Regeln auch beim Bernsteinzimmer ansetzen. Dass du das nicht machen darfst. Das du einfach nicht machen darfst. Also das Bernsteinzimmer ist ein berühmter, mit Bernstein verzierter Raum, der ursprünglich im Katharinenpalast bei Sankt Petersburg stand. Sein Verbleib nach dem Zweiten Weltkrieg ist eins der grössten Kunstgeheimnisse des zwanzigsten Jahrhunderts. Stopp! Geheimnisse? Das suggeriert ja, dass es jemand weiss. Ein Geheimnis ist etwas, was jemand weiss. Das Geheimnis sagt, irgendwo sagt jemand, m-m, sag's nicht. Nee, ach man, sag's doch. Ich würde sagen, es ist... Irgendwo macht jemand diese Geste mit diesem Mund zu und diesem Schlüssel wegwerfen. Ja, Genau. Unangenehm. Es machen nur unangenehme Menschen. Es ist kein Geheimnis, es ist ein Mysterium, würde ich sagen. Weil ein Geheimnis ist ja bekannt. Irgendjemand kennt es ja. Es ist ja nur manche nicht. Nach dem aktuellen Stand der Forschung gibt es keine gesicherten Erkenntnisse, das frage ich gleich, wer die bekanntesten ForscherInnen sind, über den Verbleib des Bernsteinzimmers. Es existieren verschiedene Theorien. Erstens, Zerstörung. Lame. Eine Möglichkeit ist es, dass bei der Belagerung von Königsberg 1945 zerstört wurde. Zweitens, Versteck in Deutschland. Okay. Einige Experten vermuten, dass Teile in Deutschland versteckt wurden, möglicherweise in alten Bergwerken oder Bunkern. Auch da würde ich ja behaupten, die hat man ja grösstenteils auch inzwischen mal von innen sich angeguckt. Oh, ne, ne, da gibt's noch richtige Katakomben. Stefan, das unterschätzt du. Boah, das war eine Unterschätzung, meine Herren, das würde ich ... War das gerade eine Unterschätzung? Das war ja vorsichtig. Russland. Es gibt wirklich unendliche Katakomben unter allen Städten. Es gibt Spekulationen, dass das Zimmer heimlich nach Russland zurückgebracht wurde. Na klar, von der Roten Armee, ja. Gern mit dem zurückgebracht. Es ist ein Zimmer. Ja? Immerhin nicht das Zimmer, ich meine die Einrichtung des Zimmers. Es ist ein Zimmer, du kannst ja ein Zimmer auch bewegen. Nein, natürlich. Wie kommt es denn aus, wenn es im Katharinenpalast stand? Durch die Tür. Das Zimmer verlässt das Zimmer durch die Tür. Tür kleiner als Zimmer. Nach meiner Definition sind Türen kleiner als Zimmer. Aber wie kommt ein Zimmer in ein Haus? Es kommt ja irgendwie rein und dann kommt es ja wieder raus. Okay, Schachmatt. Andere Verstecke. Weitere Theorien sprechen von Verstecken in Polen, der Tschechischen Republik oder sogar auf dem Meeresgrund der Ostsee. So, und da kann ich von eigener Erfahrung sprechen. Bernstein kann schwimmen, verdammt nochmal. Das kann nicht am Meeresboden liegen. Zimmer gehen aber unter. Nein, nur weil etwas in Zimmerform ist, heißt es nicht, dass es automatisch untergeht. Du hast ganz merkwürdige Zimmerregeln in deinem Kopf. Du hast so eingebrannte, indoktrinierte Zimmerregeln in deinem Schädel. Die Titanic ist auch untergegangen, obwohl Holz
schwimmt und da ist ein Holzdeck.
Ja, aber das waren hunderte Zimmer, die Titanic.
Klar, und? Viele Zimmer zusammen
können sinken. Wer sagt, dass es Berndschutz überweist
eine Titanic? Kann auch sein.
Das sollte geheim nach New York. Ja, aber dann wärst du ja untergegangen,
du Arschloch. Ja, mit der Titanic.
Ja, gut, dass es ohne
etwas in der Ostsee untergegangen ist.
Ach, das ist ja Unsinn, das ist ja Nonsens.
Trotz der reichen Situationen, Untersuchungen, bleibt das Schicklein des Bandschers immer bis heute ungeklärt.
Wer sind die führenden ForscherInnen?
Hauf jetzt.
Jetzt wird hier nicht meine Familie gedokst hier.
Gut, wir sind bei sechs, sieben, also Paul Enke, Jürgen Trittin,
Max Mutzke, Nugas Wiesolski. Eine wilde, eine bunte Truppe, sagen wir uns. Eine recht bunt gemischte Personengruppe. Boah, das klingt wie ausgedacht, das klingt wie so ein Impro-Spiel. Paul Enke, ein deutscher Autor und Forscher, Jürgen Trittin, ein deutscher Forscher, wir meinen wahrscheinlich nicht den Politiker, Catherine Scott-Clark und Adrian Levy, britische Journalisten, die ein bekanntes Buch über das Verschwinden des Berndungszimmers verfasst haben, Anatoly Mosquin, ein russischer Historiker, Mario Morgner, ein deutscher Historiker, das klingt wie das alte Ego, was sich der Mom überlegt hat, wahrscheinlich weil sie anonym bleiben wollte, Mario Morgner, Günter Wermusch, ein deutscher Journalist und Autor, der mehrere Bücher über das Berndungszimmer geschrieben hat, und Konstantin Akin Gregorik Kozlov. Gut, aber das sind die Feinde, ne? Das ist ja schon klar. Also das ist jetzt eigentlich die Killlist. Wir stellen uns einen Film vor, einen Filmposter. Und das sind so im Hintergrund diese Bösen. Und im Vordergrund ist seine Mutter eine unschuldige Mom, die noch so eine Küchenschilze anhat und so. Und irgendwie gerade so von allem von den Jungs macht sie so aus dem Mundwinkel noch die Nutella weg. Sie sucht vor, im Hintergrund sehen wir die ganzen Konstantin Akincher und Grigory Koslow mit so einer Augenklappe, der im Hintergrund so grinst. Das finde ich stark. Das finde ich auch gut, ja. Die Suche nach dem Bernsteinzimmer. Ja, ich bin gespannt. Wir haben ja schon mal berichtet davon, seitdem ist tatsächlich gar nichts passiert.
Also ich warte immer nur darauf, dass es aus der Heimat dann auch mal wieder ein paar Nachrichten gibt, Updates oder so, aber da kommt ja wirklich gar nichts.
Deswegen, vielleicht muss ich da irgendwann mal nachhelfen und das dann mal so in die Wege leiten.
Nachfragen müssen helfen.
Dass man das dann einfach mal so beim Bäcker oder so dahinstellt oder so und dann findet es meine Mutter aus Versehen.
Da müssen wir mal gucken, wie wir das letztendlich machen. Aber ja. Aber es ist immer gut, was Leute so nach dem Ruhestand, ich weiss nicht, ob der noch aktiv ist, was die dann so machen, ne? Also so Leute, die lange in der öffentlichen, so Edward Snowden oder so, da warte ich auch immer so, da kommt da noch was. Der ist ja auch in Russland untergetaucht oder so, ich meine, kommt da noch mal irgendwas? Irgendwann kommt da mal so ein Album oder irgendwie so ein Malt was oder so. Was ist mit dem, der aus dem Weltall gesprungen ist? Ja, Baumgartner, Felix Baumgartner. Den Namen, den weißt du sofort. Ja, aber das ist ja so meine Hotlist. Der ist dann, glaube ich, auch so ein bisschen schwurbelig geworden oder so. Vielleicht ist er da dann so irgendwie getaumelt. Wieso hat er gesehen? Nee, das ist... Splat-Earth-er geworden. Wie schwurbelig. Ah, das wäre fantastisch. Wenn der so... Er landet unten und sagt, Leute, ihr glaubt nicht, was ich gesehen habe. Das wäre der beste Prank ever. Ohne Witz, das ist wirklich eine Scheibe. Glaub mir, ich habe es gesehen. Die Nase liegt. Von oben eine Scheibe. Ich war ja oben. Ich habe wirklich gesehen, je höher man geht, desto dünner wird's. Und vom Forscher sagen so, nee, es gibt Berechnungen. Und er sagt, ja, ich hab's gesehen. Ich war oben. Guck runter. Es war eine Scheibe. Ja, aber sie war noch nicht ganz oben. Ich hab's gesehen. Ich war hoch genug. Ah, das wär fantastisch. Aber man könnte, aber da bist du eigentlich, hast du ausgesorgt fürs Leben. Wenn du wirklich so eine Flat-Earth-Ikone wirst, bist du eigentlich, also, wenn du wirklich gar, wenn du wirklich, dein Terminkalender ist bis zu dem Tag ja sehr gefüllt. Du musst Sauerstofftests machen, du musst körperlich fit sein, damit dieser Sprung klappt, du musst es klären mit den Organisatoren, Materialprüfung, Test und so. Also du hast sehr viel zu tun, du hast kaum Freitage. Dann ist es einmal gesprungen von weit oben. Aber du siehst ja in deinem Terminkalender, du scrollst und ab einem gewissen Punkt hast du ganz viele Punkte bei den Tagen. Und ab dem Tag gar nichts mehr. Ein Punkt noch Pressetermin, Debriefing. Genau, Pressemitteilung, aber danach nichts mehr. Du denkst, oh verdammt. Und dann sagst du, nimmst du vielleicht den...
Ich falle erst auf die Erde und dann auf ein Loch, in ein Loch. Stürze dich noch tiefer und dann sagst du, okay, dann gehe ich in die Verschwörungstheorie-Business. Also jetzt, ne, gut, Triggerwarnung, Joke kommt jetzt, aber es wäre ein bisschen lustig, wenn er dich danach, wenn er danach von der Brücke gesprungen wäre. Ja, genau, wenn alles sicher geklappt hätte, wunderbar, ja.
Aber das wäre natürlich auch eigentlich die klassische Icarus-Sage. Er ist eigentlich der, der am höchsten geflogen ist, am nähersten an der Sonne. Das ist der gegenteilige Icarus ein bisschen. Weil ihm ging es ja nicht um die Nähe zur Sonne, sondern ihm ging es immer um den Sprung zurück.
Ich weiß nicht, ob der so lange drüber nachdenken muss.
Naja, Moment mal.
Nein, nein, hol jetzt nicht aus.
Icarus wollte hochfliegen und ist dann gestürzt.
Genau.
Baumgartner wollte aber von Anfang an runterstürzen.
Ja, ja.
Also, wäre eigentlich sein Icarus im Moment gewesen, wenn er nicht hätte fallen können.
Auf der Art hast du recht, weil bei Icarus geht es ja im Kern, du darfst nicht zu viel wollen, und da ist er ja auch. Nur war der Sprung quasi intrinsisch in der Idee. Also eigentlich, wenn er oben gemerkt hätte, er kommt nicht weg, er muss wieder runterfahren, er kann nicht springen, das wäre dann die Icarus-Moment. Du sollst nicht zu hoch. Weil er ironisch gewesen wäre, weil er runtergebracht worden wäre, langsam. Genau, er wäre langsam runtergebracht. Das Gegenteil eines Sturzes.
Richtig, und damit eigentlich sein grösster Fall.
Und womit dann Icarus
widerlegt wäre, einfach auch als Gedankenexperiment.
Und dann hätten wir das endlich mal vom Tisch,
diesen Quatsch, dass wir diese uralten
Sachen wie
Icarus und Daedalus
hieß der andere. Was hatten die?
Der hat die Warnung ausgesprochen, fliegt nicht zu hoch.
Und ja, an den erinnert sich heute keiner mehr. Du? Ich auch, gut, ist auch ein Alte mit Dota. Dota ist aber es, ich meine nur, ist das nicht die eigentliche? Die Fans. Aber das ist ein ganz anderes Thema, gerade an der Stelle, aber ich finde das gut, dass wir das nochmal aufarbeiten. Ja. Mit Flügeln, mit Wachs. Also vielleicht ist auch einfach Sicherheit, Safety first. Naja, jetzt habe ich einmal das gelesen auf dem Weg hierher, dann dachte ich mir, ich kann das ja mal mit einbringen. Ich finde das super, ich denke mir, was ein Idiot mit Wachs. Wachsflügel. Ja, ist auch die Frage, lobt man ihn, dass er es so weit geschafft hat, überhaupt so hoch zu fliegen, dass er zur Sonne geflogen ist? Oder sagt man, du Depp, das war ja völlig offensichtlich, du Wachsflügel, du kann man sein. Zwei Perspektiven, zwei unterschiedliche Perspektiven, die man auf die Sache nehmen kann. Ich habe es ja gerade eingeben, die Frage, oben hat es die KI dem Ganzen eine Überschrift gegeben. Ja. The Mysterious Fate of the Amber Room. Und es klingt tatsächlich wie ein Harry Potter Teil. Das ist richtig gut, ja. Wenn man sowas auch noch mit reingebracht hätte, so wirklich weltliche Probleme bei Harry Potter, einfach nochmal so. Harry Potter and the Mysterious Fate of the Amber Room. Das wäre doch mal ein Twist, wenn ein Horcrux das Elfenbein, das Bernschutz-Zimmer gelesen wäre. Und dann denkst du ja so, Moment, ein Horcrux war schon der Eiffelturm und jetzt noch ein Horcrux. Und Berndschutz? Und wo da so vor so richtig weltlichen Problemen steckt, so, wo ist das denn? Die Rote Armee hat im Zweiten Weltkrieg und man denkt sich, du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du. Okay, also die Rote Armee als General-Kruschef damals driftete so komplett ab in der anderen Welt. Und ein Horcrux ist die Mona Lisa? Oh nee, da ist immer so viel los. Dann steht er im Louvre mit seinem Zauberstab in der Hand. Harry Potter! Und dann kommt so ein Typ und sagt, nee, bitte keine Zauberstab. Bitte auch keine Zauberstabe. Bitte einfach Rucksack nach vorne nehmen und keine Zauberstabe.
Ja, na ja. Ich habe mich mit jemandem unterhalten, der meinte, ja, ich interessiere mich ja sehr viel Kunst.
Also ich finde das klasse und habe mich nie lange jetzt damit beschäftigt.
Die Kindheit fand ich, die Schule fand ich es immer lame und so, aber jetzt so die letzten Jahre habe ich mich echt mit beschäftigt und so verschiedene Künstler, irgendwie Kunstepochen und so, bin da so ein bisschen reingekommen, Museen und so und ich muss aber echt sagen, wenn ich mich festlegen müsste, mein Lieblingskunstwerk ist die Mona Lisa. Da dachte ich mir schon, nope. Nee, das kannst du nicht machen. Aber es kann ja sein.
Ja, aber selbst dann musst du lügen.
Selbst wenn du ein Riesenmusikfan bist und dein Lieblingslied ist Imagine von John Lennon,
dann musst du lügen.
Das geht nicht, weil du nimmst dir jede Glaubwürdigkeit
und deine ganze Leidenschaft ist in Müll.
Ja, nein.
Es ist natürlich das berühmte Kunstwerk und so. Aber klar, wenn du so ein Film-Buff bist und du sagst, schon Star Wars. Ja, das geht dann irgendwie nicht so. Nee, du hast dann recht, du musst lügen. Du musst dann lügen, das geht nicht anders, weil du hast keine Glaubwürdigkeit. Du musst irgendwie so ein altes Kunstwerk, das wird nur in Büchern beschrieben, von Gemi Krimanetsch, der damals im tuechischen Untergrund das verbrennen musste, um vor den Kommunisten zu fliehen. Das ist echte Kunst für mich. Da gibt es das Werkverzeichnis und da gibt es diese tollen Beschreibungen darüber. Ja, Raudin hat da meine Kurzgeschichte gemacht. Angeblich ist jemand blind geworden und hat sich die Augen ausgestochen, nachdem er das Bild gesehen hat. Ja, und dann ein Künstler wollte das nachmalen und ist wahnsinnig daran geworden, weil er das nicht hingekriegt hat. Da hat sich alle Finger abgeschnitten, weil er nicht mehr malen wollte. Und dann wollte er mit seinen eigenen blutigen Fingern malen. Und das hat auch nicht geklappt. Und das musste dann auch nochmal verbrannt werden und all das hin und so. Und das ist mein Lieblingskunstwerk. Nö, schon die Mona Lisa. Ich bin jetzt mega so in Architektur drin. Ich liebe Architektur. Ich finde Architektur richtig geil. Das ist ein spannendes Thema, ein super spannendes Thema. Ich bin seit Monaten mega tief eingestiegen. Und ich bin ja jetzt seit Monaten mega tief eingestiegen. Und ich liebe Bauwerke und ich liebe Epochen. Hast du auch ein Lieblingsbauwerk, was dir am besten gefällt? Ja, also nach allen Überlegungen muss ich wirklich sagen, das Sydney Opera House. Okay. Ach gut, das kenne ich auch noch. Das wäre das einzige Gebäude, das ich kenne. Nach dem Eiffelturm vielleicht. Aber da muss man ja sagen, Mona Lisa ist ja anscheinend so bekannt, weil sie mal geklaut wurde.
Man glaubt ja tatsächlich, dass die, die da im Louvre hängt, nicht die echte Mona Lisa ist. Wo ist die echte Mona Lisa? Hängt die dann irgendwo, ist sie dann Teil von Görings Kunstschatz oder ist die irgendwo undercover? Aber es gibt ja schon, es gibt glaube ich gerade so einen Podcast, der da wirklich mal gut einsteigt in diese Geschichte, wo es mal geklaut wurde, von jemandem, der auch im Sicherheitsdienst war irgendwie erst. Was für ein Sicherheitsdienst, vom Louvre. Genau, das wurde mal, die wurde ja ab und zu mal weggeschafft. Ich weiß es nicht. Was ich gehört habe, was mega krass ist, wenn du sehr reich bist, kannst du Kunstwerke beleihen. Also angenommen, du hast ein krasses Bild bei dir hängen und du brauchst Bargeld dringend, dann beleihst du das Kunstwerk, dann kannst du immer noch bei dir hängen, theoretisch. Fühl mich mal grammatikalisch kurz durch das Wort Beleien. Ich glaube, das ist nämlich die Krux. Du verleihst es nicht, weil es bleibt in deinem Besitz. Du beleihst es, weil du quasi Geldwert bekommst, dadurch, dass die Bank du überschreibst quasi den Besitz.
Ist das nicht einfach Fairlein für einen Zeitraum, den Besitz übergeben?
Ja, aber das klingt halt nicht wichtig genug.
Okay.
Weil da geht es ja um sehr viel. Ich verstehe. Also da brauchst du ein neues Wort. Kratsche. Ja, ja. Verstehst du nicht? Manchmal reichen die Wörter für das, worum es hier geht, nicht aus. Absolut. Du, ich war auch kurz davor, nicht nachzufragen, weil das so ein, oh, das ist so ein wichtiges Wort. Wenn ich dir was Krasses schenke, habe ich dich reich beschenkt. Ich habe dir nicht was geschenkt. BE macht Dinge krasser. BE als Präfix. Es geht darum, ich habe das Bild verliehen, aber ich habe dich belien. Mit dem Bild. Ist die Frage, worüber redest du? Liest du über den Beleiten oder über das Leigeleite? Ah ja, ja. Nee, da kannst du sagen, ich hab's verliehen. Ich hab meine Inliner verliehen. Ich hab meine Kugelschreibersammlung übers Wochenende verliehen. Kriegst du ja kaum noch zurück. Du hast mir was geliehen, was ich jetzt weggeschmissen habe. Ja? Ja. Und die Tatsache, dass du nicht mehr weißt, was es ist, zeigt, dass Leinen eigentlich nur eine Art von Müllentsorgung ist. Was habe ich dir verliehen? Das weißt du nicht mehr. Doch, sag mal bitte. Ne, weißt du nicht mehr. Weißt du nicht mehr und jetzt ist es weg. Ich habe es weggeschmissen. Was habe ich dir denn geliehen? Du hast mir vor Jahren das mal ausgeliehen. Buch? Das musst du unbedingt mal, das ist klasse. Und jetzt habe ich es weggeschmissen. Jetzt bin ich ja gerade dabei, meine Wohnung auszuräumen. Aber jetzt ist es nicht brennen. Wenn es ein Buch war, bin ich sauer. Habe ich weggeschmissen. Aber du kannst nicht sauer sein. Aber du kannst nicht sauer sein, weil es dir bis zu dem Zeitpunkt ... Ja, du hast ein Recht. Du es überhaupt nicht mehr weißt. Ich habe es recht verspielt. Ich habe es recht juristisch verspielt, sauer zu sein mit meinem Unwissenheit. Deine Emotionen sind illegal.
Du kannst mir deine Emotionen jetzt nicht in Rechnung
stellen. Meine Emotionen sind verjährt.
Genau, ja. Richtig. Bis vor
ein paar Jahren hättest du die Emotionen noch haben dürfen,
jetzt sind sie weg. Mit dem Wissen, dass ich es jetzt
verspielt habe und auch nicht sauer bin,
kannst du mir sagen, was es war? Nee, aber das ist ja,
macht ja keinen Unterschied mehr. Ich würde es halt einfach
keinen Unterschied. Ich finde es aber auch jetzt super antiklimatisch, wenn du es nicht erzählst.
Weil es ja ohnehin schon weg war.
Also es war ja aus deinem Leben bereits weg.
Es macht ja gar keinen Unterschied mehr.
Es ist schon weg.
Es war ein Theaterstück, das du mir in Buchform geliehen hast.
Das du nicht gelesen hast, das ich nicht gelesen habe und das jetzt entsorgt wurde. Dürrenmatt? Oder was? Dürrenmatt! Was für die andere Stücke mag ich... Hat jemand so Dürrenmatt? Ja, weil ich mag viele Dramen von ihm sehr. Würdest du wirklich einen Dürrenmatt aus der Hand geben? Es war kein Dürrenmatt, es war ein Landis. Ach so, okay, gut. Ja, Bullshit. Gerne wegschmeißen war auch nicht gut, oder? Ich mag das nicht, dass du Bücher wegschmeißt. Ich lege die einfach bitte auf die Strasse. Habe ich auch tatsächlich Ärger bekommen, dass ich das doch verkaufen soll und so, aber ja, ist aktuell nicht so wirklich möglich. Und ähm ... Ja, bei dir ist halt so eine Situation, dass du ... Du bist ja nicht mehr hier. Du könntest es einfach auf die Strasse stellen, wie gesagt. Das ist auch nicht aufwendig. Und dann nehmen sich Leute die Bücher raus. Es bleibt halt Argo über. Ich finde, ab dem gewissen Punkt ist es einfach, du stellst Herrn Müller auf die Strasse. Aber ich weiß, wir haben anscheinend eine Community, die sehr allergisch auf Wegschmeissen im Allgemeinen ist, wo wir sehr grossen Ärger immer kriegen, weil man gewisse Dinge nicht wegschmeissen darf, andere schon. Und ich habe noch nicht ganz verstanden, wo die Linie ist, aber es ist ja auch okay. Ich kann ja auch verstehen, dass man ... Es ist eine Riesenlinie und die ist ganz viel weiter rechts, als wir denken.
Ja, genau, richtig.
Also die ist viel weiter, also eigentlich nichts wegschmeißen.
Erstmals auf die Straße stellen.
Genau, verschenken, weitergeben.
Ich habe neulich meine Klamotten ausgemistet und hatte sehr viele Bügel plötzlich über.
So viele Bügel, dass ich noch welche dachte, wenn mir Klamotten dazukommen, brauche ich ja wieder Bügel, da habe ich mir sehr viele zur Seite gelegt und da hatte ich immer noch sehr viele Bügel, dass ich noch welche gedacht habe, wenn wir Klamotten dazukommen, brauche ich ja wieder Bügel, habe ich mir sehr viele zur Seite gelegt und hatte immer noch sehr viele Bügel über. Dann habe ich die in einem Koffer, den ich auch nicht mehr brauchte, mit der Community im Ohr, habe ich die Bügel in dem Koffer auf die Strasse gelegt zum Verschenken und dann gucke ich ganz gerne immer raus, also ich wünsche mir dann immer einen zurecht, weil dann lege ich meinen Müll auf die Strasse. Und dann habe ich immer Angst, das zu sehen, wie es jemand nimmt. Ich finde das irgendwie unangenehm. Und dann gucke ich so nach Stunden aus meinem Fenster und sehe, dass der Koffer weg ist und auf der ganzen Strasse verteilt Bügel liegen. Also es ist wirklich so ein schlimmer Anblick. Es ist wirklich der schlimmste Anblick. Ich weiß gar nicht, was ich erwartet habe, was ich sehe. Meistens ist dann immer alles weg. Oder es liegt das Argo noch da rum oder ein anderer umliebter Gegenstand. Aber in diesem Beispiel war halt die ganze Straße voller Bügel auf der Straße. Es war wirklich so, es hat man den Koffer genommen, dann so ausgekippt und dann die Bügel genommen und einmal so verteilt weggeworfen.
Und genau so stelle ich mir meine Strasse auch vor, wenn ich da eine ganze Box von Hegel hinstelle und so am Ende das dann da durch den Dreck geflattert wird. Und das will man ja auch nicht sehen, wirklich. Man will nicht Hegel auf der Strasse sehen. Nee, du willst Hegel nicht mit Füssen getreten im Matsch auf der Strasse sehen. Das ist ein unschöner Anblick. Das willst du nicht sehen. Dann würdest du so aus deinem Fenster rufen, so weit ist es gekommen, Hegel auf der Strasse, Hegel ist auf der Strasse sehen. Das ist ein unschöner Anblick. Das willst du nicht sehen. Dann würdest du so aus deinem Fenster rufen, so weit ist es
gekommen, Hegel auf der Strasse!
Hegel ist auf der Strasse!
Aber gehört er nicht genau dahin?
Ruft ein anderer aus dem Fenster? Ja, vielleicht,
ich weiss nicht. Ah, okay, man entbricht
und dann weiss man nicht, mit wem man diskutiert.
Im Kölner Norden entbricht dann plötzlich
Sonne. Es ist ohnehin,
es braucht wenig, um Menschen zum Extrem
zu führen, auf jeden Fall. Ich war jetzt unterwegs und in Hamburg, es gibt ja die grosse Elbe, Fuck-Fluss, sage ich jetzt hier. Wieso? Es ist ein Fuck-Fluss, weil der einfach so fucking im Weg ist, wer baut eine Stadt an Fluss, einfach dümmste Idee ever. Alle, alle, alle. Leider war das mal in Mode, einfach saudumme Idee, weil der Fluss im Weg ist. Und es gibt einfach nur zwei Übergänge, es gibt Brücke und Tunnel. Und das war's. Und jetzt war der Tunnel gesperrt und da liegt alles lahm, alles brach. Und es ist an drei Stunden, und ich war so fucking wütend. Ich war wirklich, glaube ich, zwei Stunden lang am Stück richtig wütend. Ja, so kenne ich dich gar nicht. Stau, und dann gibt es halt die Situation, Stau, alles staut sich, lange Strasse, und dann gibt es so einen Parkplatz rechts. Und dann sind Leute natürlich ganz schlau, die fahren von hinten auf den Parkplatz, fahren ein paar ein Stück an dem Stau vorbei und wollen sich dann vorne wieder reindrängeln. Und ich habe wirklich gepoltert. Ich habe wirklich und vor allem, die haben keine Vorfahrt. Die haben keine fucking Vorfahrt. Und ich hab gesagt, lass die nicht wieder rein. Die sollen da verdörren auf ihrem Scheiß irgendwie Vordrängel umweg da so. Wenn die niemand reinlässt, dann wäre Gerechtigkeit hergestellt, weil dann würden die da einfach versauern da. Und alle so, lassen die da rein und verstehen gar nicht, was da vor sich geht. Die wissen ja im Zweifel gar nicht, dass die rechts da gefahren sind. Richtig, die vorne, die Schwachen, die verstehen das nicht. Und ich dachte mir wirklich, ich stelle mich da jetzt einfach davor und lasse da niemanden mehr durch. Einfach, ich zünde jetzt einfach die Kamikaze-Granate und stelle mich davor und dann kommen wir alle nicht mehr voran, einfach nur damit diese Person nicht weiterkommt. Ich war so wütend. Ja, das ist mir ja auch schon mal passiert. Ich war ja auch mal diese Person, weil mein Google auf Arschloch gestellt war. Ja, das fasziniert mich immer noch. Da achtet man darauf, dass Google auf Arschloch gestellt ist. Dann fahrt ihr ab und das war ich ja unfreiwillig, war ich dann so. Genau, fahr auf der Autobahn ab und ich sehe nur oben einen rechten Fahrstreifen von uns. Ich dachte, der will hier abfahren und eine andere Route nehmen. Und dann sah man aber erst nach und nach, dass er einfach gerade ausfahren will, an allen vorbei, um dann wieder aufzufahren. Das ist unglaublich. Und du spasst im Zweifel, je nach Ausfahrt und wie lang die so ist, sparst du schon ein bisschen. Das darf nicht. So einen Kilometer habe ich schon überfahren dann. Ich war wirklich so wütend, es war wirklich ein Ausnahmezustand. Und dann sehe ich nur, endlich geht es so ein bisschen weiter und dann vor mir war ein Blink an und dann ist jemand das Auto abgeschmiert, einfach direkt auf der Fahrbahn mitten im Stau. Und da wirklich so, ich dachte mir, die Welt geht hier zu Ende einfach so. Das ist so, das Auto war ein Fehler. Das Auto war ein Fehler. Ich meine so Pferde und so. Was für ein Stau mit Pferden? Ich kann es mir nicht vorstellen. Weil die Pferde, du kannst sie auch so vorbeidrängeln oder dann so drüber springen oder irgendwie sowas in der Richtung. Aber das war ein Fehler. Wir haben Fehler gemacht. Menschheit, lass uns mal ein paar Fehler einfach wieder zurück. Meine Top drei schlimmsten Wutausbrüche waren mit Sicherheit alle im Auto. Auf jeden Fall. Also, ich erinnere mich an meinen schlimmsten Ausbruch von Wut aller Zeiten. Das stimmt nicht, einmal war FIFA. Da habe ich Gott im Controller geschmissen. Nicht stolz drauf, so gegen die Wand. Ist der Controller kaputt gegangen? Ich glaube ja. Okay, zumindest. Das ist schon mal gut. Und dann, boah, dieser Selbsthass, der dann sofort reinkommt. Das Schlimmste war aber, glaube ich, im Auto. Und da wollte ich Siri dann irgendwie was sagen, wie schreib dem und dem die und die Nachricht, weil sie mir dringend war. Und ich war auf der Autobahn, konnte er da jetzt nicht am Handy rumfummeln. Und dann habe ich diese Funktion nutzen wollen. Und jetzt falsch verstanden. Vielleicht war es auch irgendwie so, rufe Florentin Will an. Ich habe Florentin Will folgende Suchergebnisse zu Florentin Will. Nein, rufe Florentin Will an. Ah, ich rufe Hildegard Billenstedt an. Nein, rufe und irgendwann habe ich so geschrien. Fieri! Also es war wirklich, das war Willis Laustärke. Nein! So war das. So geschrien in meinem kleinen Autochin. Alleine. Ich dachte, es gibt wie viel Wut hier gerade. Und in irgendeinem Film habe ich neulich so eine Szene gesehen, wo es auch nicht geklappt hat mit der Fernsteuerung von einem Handy. Ich glaube, man könnte ein Auto ohne weiteres einfach nur mit der Wut des Fahrers antreiben. Also wenn du es einfach, vor allem wenn es langsamer wird, schreist du mehr und könntest dadurch einfach wieder mehr Energie erzeugen und das Auto wieder fahren lassen. Vielleicht ist das der Antrieb der Zukunft. Falls BMW hier zuhört oder Kia, ich glaube, ich brauche eher so ein Underdog, die dann damit so anfangen, ruft uns gerne an. Also da ist genug Wut da auf jeden Fall. Ja, und deswegen mag ich ja sowas wie Fiat 500 oder so ein Twingo. Also süße Autos mit vielen Rundungen und die vorne so ein freundliches Gesicht haben. Weil je alberner das Auto, desto weniger hast du ein Recht und fühlst dich auch im Recht, Wut zu haben oder so ein Arschloch-Move zu machen. Ich behaupte, im Fiat 500 machst du statistisch, da muss man mal eine Studie anfertigen,
weniger diesen Arschloch-Move über die Ausfahrt als so ein Dreier-BMW.
Gibt es Automodelle, die Arschlochverhalten begünstigen?
Auf jeden Fall. Also so alles getunte, Unterbodenbeleuchtung, ist das noch ein Thing? Weiß ich nicht.
Lotusartige Sportwagen, Giftgrün, ich glaube Farben spielen da auch eine Rolle, Farblehre.
Was hat Goethe dazu gesagt, die wütendste Farbe oder die grösste Arschlochfarbe, was es da gibt?
So matt, matt oder so glaube ich.
Ja, so schwarz-matt oder so kaki-matt. Also alles, was in die Militärrichtung geht.
Das Olivgrün.
Weg, einfach direkt weg und taxen. Taxen raus. Taxen raus, einfach sofort. Taxen, taxen. Ja, ja, nee, das war eine ganz, ganz schlimme Fahrt. Eine ganz, ganz schlimme Fahrt. Okay, aber du hast es überstanden, du bist nicht zu wütend geworden. Fucking El, Mann, fucking Fluss. Du hast die Elbe. Fucking Fluss. Aber den Rhein, hast du gegen den Rhein auch so schlimm? Gar nichts, aber der Rhein habe ich kaum, dass der im Weg ist irgendwie im Gefühl. Ich weiss nicht, ob das in Hamburg so schlimm ist, dass man da das Gefühl hat, da ist so, hau ab mit deinen Wassermassen da. Hau ab einfach, weg, weg, so das ist einfach, weg mit dem ganzen Wasser so, kann das nicht einfach so ein bisschen. Aber wenn ein Zimmer umgesiedelt werden kann, dann kann doch, und damals, da war man noch nicht so weit technisch, dann kann man doch jetzt mit der ganzen Stadt Hamburg, Tipp, wir ziehen um. Man nimmt es Hamburg und zieht es um. Ja, oder mach den Fluss so unterirdisch oder irgendwie sowas, dass der einmal so unter, einmal gesaugt wird unter der Stadt durch und dann auf der anderen Seite wieder raus. Also weil die Schiffe gucken, dass die halt dann auch mitgesaugt werden. Ich habe eine Idee gehabt, wie man Staus regulieren kann, nämlich mit so wie so Riesenbrücken und die kommen dann von oben auf die Autobahn drauf und du machst sie direkt doppelt so viele Spuren, weißt du? Also, es ist so eine riesen Doppeldeckerstrasse. Es sind so fünf Kilometer Brücken, genau, Doppeldeckerstrasse und du lässt die oben drauf. Und dann können manche die Ausfahrt auch oben nehmen und manche können unten drunter herfahren. Und wie kommt die Strasse dahin? Also dann mit Hubschraubern? Ich denke an Hubschraubern oder du denkst an Hubschrauber? Oder ich denke, das ist einfach bei stauanfälligen Stellen eingeplant. Ja, ich glaube sowieso, dass wenn du, ich finde, man sollte immer, wenn irgendwo ein Stau ist, sagen, ah, wir bauen dann noch eine Strasse dazu. Genau. Und dann, ah, da ist wieder ein Stau, noch eine Strasse dazu. Und irgendwann hast du die heißen Stellen dann irgendwie nochmal mit Ausweichstrassen gemacht. Ich meine, es gibt ja, ich meine, die grössten Staus zur Geschichte, Wyoming 2008, das war ja ein 16-jähriger Stau, wo die einfach gesagt haben, wir bauen daneben einfach eine neue Strasse. Das war einfacher als diesen Stau zu lösen, eine komplett neue Strasse. Und die stehen immer noch die armen Leute darum. Deswegen, ganz wichtiges Thema, wo wir auch nochmal dankend auf unser Reddit zukommen müssen. Ich habe mich nämlich geärgert. Worüber? Ich habe mich sehr geärgert über die Merkhilfindustrie, die wirklich brach liegt, meiner Meinung nach. Ich habe mich über Merkel geärgert. Nee, diesmal ja, ja, ja, ja, diesmal nicht tatsächlich. Ich habe mich über die Merkhilfindustrie geärgert zum Thema Rettungsgasse. Und zwar hieß es Rettungsgasse, denk an die Hand. Ja, also wo ist die Rettungsgasse, zwischen welchen Spuren ist die Rettungsgasse. Und dann soll man an die linke Hand denken, wo der Daumen ist, dann ist die grosse Abstand und dann kommen die anderen Rotzdrecksfingern. Ich hasse das. Die Hand ist kacke. Weil du weißt nicht, wie rum du die Hand halten musst. Wenn du es am Lenkrad hast, die Hand, dann ist sie falsch rum. Und deswegen hat jemand dankenswerterweise im Reddit einen viel besseren Merkspruch gepostet zum Thema Rettungsgasse, und zwar Tatütata und Tü ist die Rettungsgasse. I hate that! Ich finde den mega gut! Wie Tü ist die Rettungsgasse? Ta, Tü, Ta, Ta. Ta links, dann kommt Thü die Rettungsgasse und dann Ta, Ta rechts. Du weißt, dass du es von links nach rechts lesen musst. Ta, Tü, Ta, Ta hat was mit einer Rettungsgasse zu tun, mit einem Rettungswagen. Ta, Tü, Ta, Ta. Perfekt für mich genau richtig. Vergesst es mit der Hand. Ne, nehm ich zurück. Vergesst es mit der Hand. Ne,, nehm ich zurück. Vergesst das mit der Hand, Tatü, Tatta. Nehm ich zurück, weil alle Silben Ta sind, ausser Tü. Genau. Das habe ich erst nicht geschnallt. Ich habe gedacht, ich habe das Tü als einziges. Aber es ist ja wirklich, es ist ja Ta, Ta, Ta. Genau. Und das ist ja tatsächlich super. Perfekt. Also, rein in euren Kopf, weg mit der Hand, mit dieser dummen Handregel, rein Tatü, Tatta und dann ist keine Rettungsgasse jemals ein Problem. Es ist für mich wieifenwechsel O bis O. Finde ich immer noch super, weil O bis O wirklich ja Reifen sind. Also Oscar bis ... Ostern bis Oktober. Ach so, okay. Reifenwechsel Ostern und Oktober. Ostern und Oktober, mhm. Da muss man wissen, wann Ostern ist. Also fällt mir immer im November ein, dass O bis O die Regel ist, aber ... Neue Idee für neue Monate? Alphabetisch. April, Bombolin, Chodromesk, Deberina, Dädalos, Emil, Friedrich. Evel, Fresel, gut, du brauchst halt neue Daten. Ich wäre für die Zahlen 1 bis 12. Nee, 1 bis 10. Sagen wir 1 bis 10, dann ist glatt, weg mit der 12, weg mit 6, 6 ist eklig. Ich bin auf die Ostsee gefahren und da habe ich ein neues Problem gehabt, weil ich bin ja, Merkel, ich bin da an die Ostsee gefahren zum Schreiben. In Ruhe. Stimmt, da musst du uns eigentlich noch in der nächsten Folge ausgiebig davon erzählen, wie das lief. Mach ich. Aber ich bin hingefahren und dann höre ich nur plötzlich so ein Pfff, Pfff. Oh Re, Katze. Ich schaue auf die Frontscheibe, Steinschlag. Karglas repariert. Karglas am Arsch. Karglas hat keine Termine.
Karglas ist zu bis November.
Das war nämlich dann,
hab ich auch sofort Karglas angerufen,
weil fucking hell, es brennt sich sofort ein.
Moment, aber so richtig Riss oder Loch oder?
Richtig so Risse.
Also Loch nicht, aber so Risse.
Aber was war's?
Steine.
Steine, einfach so an der Ostsee, woher?
Nee, auf Autobahn, Richtung Ostsee.
Auf dich drauf. Was da? Oder von vorne. Und dann plötzlich hör ich so, pff, pff, einfach so an der Ostsee, woher? Nee, auf Autobahn, Richtung Ostsee. Auf dich drauf. Da war fast da. Oder von vorne. Wie so Schüsse. Und das waren Rüpel von der Brücke oder von der Strasse oder bergig? Nee, es waren kleine Kieselsteine oder was so. Die aufgeschleudert wurden von der Strasse. Vermutlich, ja. Oder gab es Bergschlag, Hangschlag? Kein Hangschlag. Nee, es war ein ganz normalahnabschnitt, und da war wahrscheinlich so ein bisschen Rollschutt auf der Autobahn, hundert, hundert, hundert natürlich für mich jetzt der Grund, erstmal nicht zu schreiben. Weil natürlich, ich bin ja nur weggefahren, weil ich hier zu Hause denke, wenn du mir eine Nachricht schreibst, wie fällt den folgenden Titel ein oder sowas, dann ist mein Tag, passiert nicht, weiß ich, aber der Tag wäre dann für mich erstmal voll, weil dann habe ich genug Ausreden, warum der Tag kreativ gut ausgeschöpft wurde und ich ja nichts mehr schreiben muss. Genau, weil dann alle, du hast ja dann die gesamte Energie fokussiert und dann der Rest wäre eh nicht so gut gewesen, weil du warst ja dann schon ausgelaugt. So schlecht, so gut im Selbstbelügen. Und das war das Problem. Und dann natürlich, das war so ein gefundenes Fressen für mich, warum der erste Tag, ja wie soll ich jetzt schreiben? Das war ja ein Schock. Ich habe jetzt Stress mit Steinschlag und so. Ich würde jetzt nur noch über Steine schreiben. Ja genau. Ich würde jetzt Steine viel zu negativ darstellen. Also wir lassen den Lettion mal zugeklappt. Richtig. Und jetzt wird es erstmal die Ostseerangstie. Wütend soll man auch nicht so ein Projekt beginnen. Nein. Das ist wirklich ganz falsch. Ich kann streng genommen sogar froh sein, überlebt zu haben. Deswegen mache ich mir jetzt erstmal so einen schönen Rotwein auf. So. Und stosse erstmal an, noch zu leben, erstmal ankommen und auf die Ostsee gucken. So fing es an. Ja, aber ich hoffe, du bist danach kreativ, produktiv geworden. Wir können ja nächste Folge, kannst du ja das Skript mal komplett vorlesen. Ich werde die nächste Folge komplett darüber, wir werden es nicht vergessen, wir werden mit Sicherheit daran denken, darüber zu erzählen. Nein, wir werden auf jeden Fall, wir werden auch das Alphabet noch vorsetzen mit den News und dann kannst du ja das komplette Skript nochmal vorlesen, damit wir wissen, ob das geklappt hat oder nicht mit einer Ostseereise, die ja anscheinend sehr stressig war. Da würde ich auch nächstes Jahr mal wieder einschalten. Nächstes Jahr wieder einschalten.
Schaltet mal nächstes Jahr wieder eins. Das würde uns freuen.
Wenn es zu unserer 2025er Folge, wenn es weitergeht mit dem Podcast Ufo.
Bis dahin ganz, ganz viel Spaß. Ganz, ganz viel liebe Grüße.
Grühtet euch, seid nicht wütend, liebe Grüße.
Nein, nein, nein. Atmet lieber mal tief durch und fahrt Fiat 500.
Ciao, it's the worst world production.